turning to breaking news tonight nevada
highway patrol says a man is dead after
a shooting involving nevada state
troopers this happened near lake mead
and boulevard and pabco road in the
northeast valley officers say they were
responding to reports the man hit a
woman inside a car kate houston joins us
live from lake mead and amona road with
the latest on this investigation tonight
kate
yes well the road behind me is now open
after it was closed for several hours
this afternoon where we are is actually
about 10 miles from where that shooting
happened this is a popular route for
people in the area to get to lake mead
many had to turn around today as a few
dozen officers conducted their
investigation
around 8 a.m this morning officers say
they received a report of a domestic
problem between a man and a woman inside
a gray toyota corolla at this time
there's no information on the
relationship between the two people
officers say at 8 19 a.m the car was
located near lake mead boulevard and
mile marker 14. at approximately 8 26
a.m
troopers reported
the officer involved shooting
following that an adult male subject was
transported to umc trauma
where he succumbed to injuries sustained
and was pronounced deceased trooper
samaka could not immediately provide
details on what prompted the shooting
nor what happened within the seven
minutes that officers located the car
and the shooting occurred
back out live officers expect to release
more information in about three days at
this time there is no update on the
woman that was involved reporting live
from lake mead animona kate houston live
local now